hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of Science
and Technology
and let's say I see a number of
questions uh
that have been saved up here there's one
from Julie here what's the history of AI
what's the first recorded example of
artificial intelligence
well in terms of first recorded example
there are certainly plenty of
mythological cases of well more like
artificial I'm not sure that there was
so much of a distinction between
artificial life and artificial
intelligence
um back in sort of ancient times
but the idea of you know lumps of clay
becoming alive and so on was was
certainly a thing it's worth remembering
that the concept of the fact that life
only comes from other life
was not was a comparatively recent
realization I mean people thought that
in a in a bunch of mud there will be
spontaneous generation of living
organisms and maggots and things like
this
um and uh part of the reason for that
was until the 1600s people didn't know
about microorganisms before there were
microscopes there wasn't any knowledge
of microorganisms
um and uh
although I think there was sort of an
implicit uh from the periods in the
1400s with the black death and things
like this there was uh sort of some
implicit knowledge of contagion and the
fact that there were invisible agents of
contagion later germs and so on
um but the idea that that life could
come from non-life
um was still really a thing
um back uh you know until solidly into
the 1600s maybe even past that time so
this idea that that um uh that life was
not creatable in an easy way was uh uh
was something that only sort of
gradually came in now of course in
today's world one's interested in you
know what's the origin of life on Earth
and uh back in the 1950s for example
there were these experiments famously
the Miller Ura experiment where you've
got a bunch of chemicals that um uh sort
of might have existed on the early Earth
and you put sort of a simulated
lightning strike through it and you
discover you get other chemicals which
are things sort of approaching the
chemicals of life I mean one of the
things that was discovered one in the
70s 80s perhaps was that in interstellar
space there are uh the chemical
reactions are very weird in that case
because the density of of material is
really low and what tends to happen is
there'll be a molecule sitting on some
grain out in the Stellar space and some
other molecule would sort of hit it and
the things will have some reaction
um but the result of all of that is that
there are molecules of of decent size
that happen to be also molecules that
appear in living systems I think the
mechanisms by which they come to be
there are utterly different from the
ones and living systems but it's sort of
notable that oh in in you know in
interstellar space there's there are uh
you know there are grains that have
these molecules on them and so on
um
so and then the question of sort of how
how life arose from non-life which and
we'll come back to intelligence in a
moment but how sort of Life arose from
non-life it's still a very much an open
question what the details of that are
and sort of how you know RNA DNA and so
on came to be
um and and how many Alternatives there
were I mean how much of what we see in
life today isn't what was originally
there you know we see in the budget
Shale for example which comes from what
um
what is it maybe 500 million years ago
something like that
um examples of organisms
um from the I guess kind of Precambrian
period when uh which were funky
organisms that don't look much like
anything we have today I mean it's kind
of like you know the right-handed
versions of molecules and sort of the
chiral structure of molecules one out in
biological organisms but maybe they're
organisms that had the left-handed
versions of sugars and other other
molecules and those ones uh didn't win
out and we don't know why and the fact
that you know there's five-fold Symmetry
and lots of things rather than six-fold
Sevenfold whatever else is another thing
where at some moment that one out in the
history of life but the question of sort
of how the first organisms that the
first way in which different kinds of
elements of organisms arose my guess is
that that a lot of different mechanisms
that exist in biological organisms sort
of originated separately and then they
all got combined together into this kind
of uh package deal that is life and I
think you know we already see that in
living organisms today our mitochondria
that are the energy source for for cells
those were separate organisms that
became parasites in what became the
whole uh line of development that leads
to eukaryotes and and like us
um
I want one would guess that the things
like the lipid bilayer of cell membranes
um was probably of a sort of a separate
origin from things about the replication
in in DNA and so on and these sort of
came together as a package deal sometime
a bit later
um you know all happening at least two
and a half billion years ago if not if
not longer ago
um I think that the whole notion of
having separate organisms as opposed to
having a sort of Mega organism that just
sort of spreads out and has little
pieces of it that was probably a thing
that that had to be invented and maybe
maybe two and a half billion years ago
or something now
um but I think the uh uh the whole
question of um well I can certainly
imagine things like lipid bilayers
forming from sort of not very biological
kinds of things and more like bubbles
that that form and reform and and uh and
so on and uh obviously now we have sort
of a technological version of something
a bit like that in the lipid
nanoparticles that are used for example
for mRNA vaccines and there's increasing
knowledge of sort of how to make things
like you know cells artificially the the
the the the the coating of cells
but in any case the I think that um uh
it's been a field this whole the whole
origin of Life field has been something
where each different piece people talk
about you know Clay for example where
you can get sort of a a solid Matrix and
then molecules being swapped in and out
and so on and that that becomes a good
place to start doing some kinds of
biological processes but uh okay so
first first thing is how did life come
from non-life and that was all a bit
muddled still not known but that's
that's one piece then there's a question
of uh intelligence you know where how do
you get artificial intelligence well I
think this notion of sort of the
disembodied intelligence idea that is
kind of a very ancient idea I mean
that's kind of related to the idea of
Souls and so on the idea that there is a
thing about brains that is not the the
concrete the not the explicit sort of
biological tissue of a brain it is
something of the sort of the the
informational engram of a brain that's
something a very ancient origin the
notion that there could be such a a kind
of an informational engram that is sort
of in a sense a perfect Immortal thing
irrespective of the its instantiation in
an actual biological tissue but I don't
think that the idea that that could be
created artificially was was really a
thing because people when people thought
about machines in Antiquity for example
well what were the machines I mean there
were Siege machines for you know for all
sorts of things in in Warfare there was
also this one example that we have of
the anti-cathera device this Clockwork
computer that came from somewhere
between 100 BC and 100 A.D roughly found
in this particular shipwreck off this
island off of this Greek island
um this particular device is a kind of
many cogged uh small you know it's not
big things but it's like size of a two
hands or something
um it's it's in a museum in Athens now
um the uh
the thing is uh you know a whole
collection of cogs that seems to be
something for computing well was
something for computing astronomical
events and so on I don't think anybody
would have said of that it's an
intelligence-like thing I do know that
Cicero wrote about the existence of such
a device and it was like many of these
ancient writings uh like you know the
descriptions of Troy and Homer and
things like this people assume for a
long time that they were kind of
mythical things and it only became clear
uh sort of in later archeology that
these things were real I mean this
leaves out in the you know the question
of Atlantis you know the city that
vanished but now beneath the ocean type
thing nobody's ever found a thing that
is that and maybe it will be found and
and that generally seems to be the case
that these kind of ancient descriptions
were about something they weren't just
sort of made up out of whole cloth so to
speak but the anticothera device was
something I'm not quite sure how Cicero
described it
um but it won't have used anything that
we would recognized in sort of modern
terms as artificial intelligence now you
know by the 1600s there were lots of
clockwork devices I mean clock making
was a thing and you could have all kinds
of automata and they were called
automata that uh would be it's kind of
this this uh there's models of you know
people and animals and and so on sort of
all going around on in A Clockwork way
you know miniaturized into things like
music boxes and so on that was very much
a a known technology now again very much
a mechanical technology where I'm not
sure anybody would have thought of it as
an intelligence now of course there were
confusing things what was it the 1800s
maybe 1700s the the the so-called
Mechanical Turk you know there was a
chess playing machine that was uh you
know a box reasonably sized box that
would sort of move chess pieces around
I'm not sure whether it was magnetically
or some other way
um on on a chessboard and it was sort of
displayed around your up and so on and
and look it's a it's an intelligent
machine well it wasn't a machine there
was a a small person inside the Box who
happened to be a pretty good chess
player and who was uh manipulating the
pieces that's uh that's kind of why the
you know the the name of the the Amazon
um uh you know people doing tasks that
are specified by computer but it's
actually humans behind the scenes that's
why it gets called Mechanical Turk and
and hence the uh the strange um verb
turking
um referring to um the way that um
people get sort of a sort of a massive
of of humans to do tasks that are sort
of low-level tasks in most cases like
labeling images for um uh um uh for um
uh for machine learning and so on
um and uh but but so that was kind of a
a misfire in a sense and the artificial
in the history of artificial
intelligence a not and not really
artificial intelligence which looked
like an artificial intelligence
so then
uh coming much forward from that
um I'm not sure that
well okay so when people were first
starting to think about electronic
computers which was in the 1940s uh the
the common description was giant
electronic brains
so that was kind of the um uh the the
sort of the the the ready description of
what was going on
um that people gave to explain what a
computer was computers had started to
come into existence with the antiac with
atanasov's machine things like this they
they were they were things that had
Arisen from the use of electromechanical
technology so first of all they have the
mechanical calculators kind of clockwork
calculator like device devices then that
became electromechanical then they
weren't electronic then there was the
idea of a stored program computer where
you could have a purely electronically
specified thing that would determine the
the settings for effectively the
switches and the computer to determine
which operation would be going and
things like this and that was that was
very much by the end of the 1940s that
was sort of a known thing and then the
first kind of production computers
started existing in the 1950s and that
was say and when people were writing
about these things they were usually
describing them as things like giant
electronic brains which kind of made it
seem like the computers were doing
something that was an intelligence-like
thing and uh for example it was very
common description computers were faster
than thought so they were thinking but
they were faster than thought they were
electronic as opposed to the way that
our brains are sort of the
electrochemical processes in our brains
so I think from the very early days of
computers people had the ideas compute
the idea that computers Were Somehow
intelligent like brains and the fact
that computers were something very
different from brains I think it's
something that only gradually arose I
mean in computers as a practical matter
were first really used more for their
database qualities a little bit for
their mathematical computation but also
for the database qualities that was the
whole sort of Mainframe computer
tradition a lot of that was about kind
of database uses some of it was about
actually calculating things like
trajectories of spacecraft or or things
for engineering purposes of stress and
and structures things like this
um but I think by the time by the time
there were personal computers at the
beginning of the 1980s and in the 1970s
um the uh the question of what was a
computer for well it was for playing
computer games it was for doing word
processing it was maybe for doing
spreadsheets none of those things looked
very intelligent like they didn't look
very mind-like
now there had been sort of a tradition
in um uh among
people sort of thinking about
theoretical computation like Alan Turing
for example in 1950 wrote this uh paper
about what it would be like to have sort
of artificial intelligence what it would
be like to take this computer which here
that first imagined purely theoretically
in 1936 as the turing machine the idea
of a universal computer by 1950 he was
actually exposed to an actual computer
in Manchester
um and so electronic computers were
starting to be a thing and he was kind
of extrapolating from that what would be
what it would be would it be like when
computers were really intelligent like
people and I think that that
um was uh his some what was it called um
um intelligent Machinery I think
something like that
um was a uh piece Alan Turing wrote in
1950 which famously introduced the
so-called touring test of if you're
talking to a thing it will be all the
chat bot today if you're talking to a
chat bot can you tell if the chat bot is
a chat bot or a person a Mechanical Turk
person perhaps on the other side of the
partition and I think in in just in the
last few months I think one has probably
got to the point where that is rather
difficult to tell
um and one's way of telling would have
to be uh uh very uh sort of uh quite
quite subtle
um you know Chachi BT does a pretty good
job of being it's a little bit uh you
know it's a little bit Bland as a human
in some ways but um it is uh um it is
quite human-like and I think it would
pretty firmly pass pretty much any
version of the touring test from from
1950. but at the time so Alan Turing
defined a number of things in that very
paper that was sort of tests for was a
computer intelligent one was this Turing
test of the conversation type thing
another was for example playing games
like chess
um those were things which seemed like
they were sort of things that would be
characteristic of of something
intelligent rather than a mere
calculational device type thing
well
then 1956
there was sort of an important uh thing
which was a conference at Dartmouth I
think about artificial intelligence with
the word used and that conference was
organized I Believe by John McCarthy
Marvin Minsky perhaps called Claude
Shannon all kind of major figures in
this story and uh they uh sort of there
were several different Traditions that
were coming together at that time there
was the tradition that came from finite
automata the idea of automata I'd
mentioned were already these sort of
mechanical Clockwork type things then
there was the notion of switching
systems then Claude Shannon for example
I was pointing out Boolean algebra is
the same as switching systems then there
was kind of the idea of final automata
this was kind of a a mathematicized
version of those kind of clockwork
devices and uh that was kind of one
tradition that came in then there was
the McCulloch Pitts neural net tradition
that had been in introduced 1943 by
McCulloch Warren mcculloughton Walter
Pitts
um as their kind of idealization of what
was observed to be going on in brains
what Romani kajal had seen around 1900
as the sort of microscopic structure of
all those neurons with all these kind of
wire like tentacles coming out that was
um uh that was another
piece of the story was introducing this
kind of idea of um
uh that there will be a sort of a formal
model of that that was equivalent to
Turing machines so it was sort of known
to be computationally capable but it was
uh represented in terms of these things
that were kind of neuron-like in sort of
a formal way so that was another piece
of what sort of came into the the AI
world was um and this was all kind of
connected to things like oh I know
telephone switching equipment which
again had these sort of long wires where
things had to connect to things and so
on
and and then uh that was um uh John Von
Neumann had been involved in this wrote
a book uh the last thing he wrote I
think in his life he died in 1957 if I
remember correctly
um and uh his last book was called the
computer and the Brain that's based on
some lectures he gave at Yale
um and uh in that he's talking a lot
about McCulloch Pitt's neural Nets about
Turing machines about sort of what can
computers do
um and how brain-like are they and in
fact in the early things that Von Neiman
wrote Von Neumann was a consultant for
IBM among other things on the design of
computers famously making statements
like the United States will never need
more than five computers
um and and some other things which
weren't weren't very successfully
forward-looking uh he had reasons to say
things like that I mean maybe it's true
that the the US won't need more than
five Cloud providers but uh and that was
kind of the um uh the way that it was
being conceptualized at that time the
idea that that might be for example a
widely distributed a small or cheap
personal computer was not really on the
horizon yet so maybe maybe John Von
Neymar was right in the end if there are
only five large-scale Cloud vendors
um in the end it's his uh he's Justified
but in any case
he was some he was entrusted uh when he
was first talking about computers he
described many of the devices and
computers as organs so he would talk
about the you know the the and organ and
things like this a very biological
metaphor for what was going on in an
electronic computer all a bit kind of
confusing kind of this is it thought as
it brains is electron computers our
brains doing thinking like things but
1956 this conference about artificial
intelligence
um uh sort of the other cast of
characters involved with that uh John
McCarthy uh these are people I I knew
but um uh John McCarthy was the person
who developed lisp in the late 1950s but
he was kind of a he came from a sort of
formal mathematical tradition with
recursive functions and and things like
this but later was kind of turned into
that turned into kind of this symbolic
AI tradition of uh uh of being able to
specify how uh sort of how intelligence
works by things that were a bit like
mathematical logic where you would
actually be describing kind of um
operations in a in a formal way with
with kind of sort of formal symbolic way
Marvin Minsky another character who was
involved in that 1956 conference he'd
done his PhD thesis at Princeton about
uh neural Nets actually
um people didn't really know quite what
to make of it but he sort of started off
in this in this more neural net learning
I I mean to just explain the sort of the
notion of you can compute things you can
do an explicit sort of symbolic
computation that's sort of plan a plan B
is you can sort of vaguely learn things
and you can sort of statistically
approximate what's happening that's kind
of the plan B neural net type idea in
modern times I would say that kind of
the the chat GPT world of large language
models is kind of the evolved version of
statistical AI are kind of the things
that we do in Wilson language and so on
are probably the evolved version of
symbolic AI uh very interesting to see
those things um uh be be connected
together but that's that's a different
story but the thing that um uh is um
back in those days uh sort of John
McCarthy was sort of emerging into the
symbolic AI would eventually develop
lisp and so on uh Marvin Minsky started
off in the in the sort of statistical AI
learning things but then went into a
sort of an even more symbolic kind of
description of AI where he really was
more I would say uh trying to give a
conceptual framework for how one can
think about thinking
and he would talk about things like
frames I never really completely
understood what frames were I asked them
about them many times but um I I'm not
sure uh that they're kind of ways and
there were I forget what they're called
um K lines maybe they're different kinds
of descriptions of sort of the thought
process I remember asking Marvin
actually once um uh one of the last
books he wrote in his life was about
emotion at least I think that book came
out he suddenly I remember him talking
about writing it and the sort of a
question of what was the type of
description what was the kind of thing
he was trying to do was it something
where you could write a piece of
software that would follow this and be a
thing that would do emotional like stuff
or was it more as I asked him something
more like what Sigmund Freud had tried
to do where you're giving kind of a a
conceptual framework for thinking about
these kinds of things which would be as
a separate problem go from the
conceptual framework to an actual
implementable kind of thing I mean it's
a little bit like you know when it comes
to Natural Selection and and you know
darwinian uh Theory and so on that's
also kind of a framework in many ways it
doesn't you know just saying natural
selection operates his heart works it's
a kind of a description of a process a
description of a mechanism but in and of
itself it doesn't let you start writing
down equations and that's a separate
overlay to go from that concerned
conceptual structure to the equations
and in a sense sort of one approach to
artificial intelligence kind of the
Marvin Minsky approach in his later
years at least was more of this what one
might call a psychological approach
where you're trying to describe
structurally what can happen and it's
then sort of a separate problem to go
Implement that
you know in the case of Marvin one of
the things that uh sort of came out was
this idea that sort of intelligence is
all about making connections between
things and so on and that did emerge
into a piece of actual sort of
Technology the connection machine
parallel computer uh that I was a
consultant to the company thinking
machines that that made that computer in
the in the early 1980s unfortunately
that computer while it had many
aspirations to be involved with the AI
really ended up being involved with with
much more in a sense mundane super
computer-ish kinds of things which it
wasn't particularly architecturally
suited to but that was kind of a a
development of kind of Marvin's concept
of you know things are it's all about
thinking is all about connections
between things and pretty soon it was an
actual thing with Asics and uh and giant
black computers with big power cables
and so on
um but uh the um
the thing that um so 1950s this kind of
uh things are sort of quite theoretical
in many ways
in the neural net side of things there
was kind of the perceptron idea a person
called Frank rosenblatt was the big
person behind that that was a kind of a
hardware implemented neural net where
you would actually have electrical wires
and thresholding units and things like
this and particularly for vision
applications you could say you know you
could do optical character recognition
you could say what characters are these
out of digits and things like this and
that that got a certain distance it was
not so much pursued at a theoretical
level well it was not so much pursued at
the level of of uh developing
large-scale sort of computer software
along these lines more it was a hardware
implementation then modeling skin simul
paper was the originator of the logo
language for example uh wrote a book
called perceptrons which for many years
killed the field because it basically
was a book that mathematically analyzed
perceptron neural Nets and showed that
sort of one layer neuron that
couldn't do anything more than
essentially linear linear algebra kinds
of operations or linear programming
kinds of operations and so people said
oh neural Nets don't do anything
interesting so that kind of killed the
statistical approach to to AI for quite
a long time there continued to be a
tradition of machine learning I don't
that name machine learning wasn't a
thing people really used much uh back in
in the 1970s even 1980s but there were a
number of techniques self-organized Maps
Associated memories all kinds of of
different methods which were all really
about approximate pattern matching of
some kind there was this kind of idea
that was Central to databases of oh
you've got this particular thing you can
find a hash code for it you can go look
that up you can go find it in the
database that was that sort of precise
information retrieval was a um I was a
well understood thing the idea of kind
of fuzzy information retrieval was
something for which there were a whole
bunch of different methodologies
um not so much neural Nets neural Nets
weren't so much of a thing there but
there were different techniques that may
yet come back for doing those kinds of
fuzzy lookups so that had been a
tradition in 1960s 70s 80s
um kind of thing
meanwhile
um in the in the world of ai ai has come
and gone multiple times
um but uh there was a sort of a another
thing in the 1960s was language
translation and text retrieval so
language translation had been this thing
very much kind of a cold war type um
um uh sort of um
you know energy put into it for that
reason you know famously there was this
idea that oh if there was some sort of
high-level uh you know Soviet American
communication maybe the translators who
were in the room would kind of throw the
whole deal by mistranslating things so
this was a U.S government kind of idea
let's get machines that can do the
translation because they'll be more
reliable and there won't be any human in
the room to kind of throw the deal of
course it didn't work out that way at
that time and and it's you know now
language translation by machine is quite
good um and but I'm not sure that I
think most people still to this to now
would be much happier to have the the
human making sure that nothing got
horribly mistranslated rather than
machine translation but in any case
times are different then and the giant
electronic brains were sort of predicted
to and expected to really kind of take
over from humans that was a thing from
the 1950s that it's just brains are
coming electronic brains are coming uh
it's um and there had been you know
there were a bunch of demos another
famous demo was uh gray Walters
um uh Turtle this was at the World's
Fair 1955 maybe it kind of was notable
enough to make itself to get itself onto
the cover of Time Magazine and things
like this it was a hemispherical turtle
shell thing that's sort of a
hemispherical shell and it had Wheels
underneath and motors and it had some
photoreceptor some photosensors as eyes
and it was a thing that tool them round
on the ground you know doing things like
following lines using using methods that
essentially came from control theory
came from the kinds of things that know
what we know had done in World War II
the things that have been done for um uh
for anti-aircraft guns and things like
this as a way of given a stimulus how do
you respond to the stimulus something
which was essentially an analog
electrical process analyzed using
control theory
um and analyzed with with kind of the
overlay of this notion of cybernetics
the you know cybernetics being defined
at that time as the sort of the analysis
of uh information and control I think in
the in in in
humans and animals and machines I think
was sort of the definition but that
later on segued very much into the very
directly mathematical and calculus-like
area of control theory but gray Walters
turtle was a notable You Know cover of
Time Magazine like creature that um uh
was you know really did things for today
would seem quite Elementary like line
following and and so on but that was
another kind of artificial intelligence
is coming type type message from the
1950s
but
okay then we got to like the 1970s well
actually I should explain another piece
to this in addition to the the interest
in language translation there was also
an interesting text retrieval uh that
really wasn't
it was a funny field because it was sort
of somewhere in between Library science
and maybe a little bit of computer
science-ish stuff
um the it was um
uh
oh dear I forgot her name uh woman in
Cambridge who was very instrumental in
in developing the ideas of of uh text
retrieval in the 1960s
um but any case the um
ah forget the name
um the uh in any case the the the next
question was sort of you got a big block
of text and you know how do you search
for words how do you retrieve things out
of that block of text there was starting
to be uh decent blocks of text I mean
there had been the science citation
index which was originally done by hand
where uh that was Gene Garfield's
Creation in the 1950s I guess where it
was like there's all this scientific
literature how you're going to find
things he had this idea of just find
everything that cites a given paper
and um the uh and then
that was those were printed things back
when I first used them in the 1970s
there were printed science citation
indices where you could go look up a
paper and you could look up all the
things that cited that paper
um uh going going into the future so to
speak and this whole that that whole
thing turned in this giant sort of
network citation Network and led to you
know kind of the bibliometrics idea and
so on Gene Garfield told me uh uh well
he was he was kind of by the time search
engines existed
um they were kind of a different
approach to finding things but Gene
Garfield pointed out to me that he had
invented page rank the the kind of
algorithm sort of popularized by by
Google and so on as a way to sort of
estimate the importance of things he'd
invented pagerank as part of his work on
bibliometrics in in um in the effort to
do uh uh to do kind of citation analysis
on um uh on scientific literature but
any case so there was another tradition
which was the kind of text retrieval
information retrieval go search for this
piece of text uh you know back in the
day you know I was all very disappointed
when search engines came out because I
had been used to old-fashioned text
retrieval systems uh for example the
dialogue system that was eventually
bought by Lockheed I think
um that was a system that allowed you to
search the abstracts of scientific
literature and it was something which
had it was it was a little bit of a a
hostile user interface I have to say
um but it had very kind of regular
expression like such syntax and you
could do things like you could say if
this word a word break could put stars
on the word to indicate arbitrary
characters and so on when search engines
came around and it was just like the
plain text it's just the words you can't
put regex regular expression pieces I
was a little disappointed by that
but any case the the um uh that was kind
of another tradition was a text
retrieval tradition that's what by the
way LED in the end the sort of a pretty
direct line from that to things like the
IBM Watson initiative that had been a
big text retrieval effort at IBM IBM had
been much involved in those kinds of
things back from the 1950s on I mean IBM
was sort of involved in the in the whole
sort of large-scale databases thing
going back to their their very early
days in the early 1900s with people like
Herman Hollerith and the kind of
automation of the census uh of the
taking of the U.S census where they've
been really punched cards Punch Cards
have invented by in 1800 for looms by by
Jacquard
um but uh the by that time they were
being used to you know you sort of
punched the information of the census
and then you can literally have a
mechanical thing that would pick up all
the cards that have this hole punched in
them corresponded to I don't know people
of age such and such whatever it is uh
the the notion of attack tabulating
machine was was sort of the the early
IBM's early uh devices were tabulating
machines used for the census uh
computation and so on but any case the
um so okay we're now in the 1970s we've
had text retrievals come into existence
there's sort of the things like lisp
that was still not very practical but it
was kind of this way of describing kind
of symbolic operations with sort of at
least a nod to kind of ideas of
mathematical logic which gave at least a
nod to ideas like predicate logic and
all the way back to kind of Aristotle
and his kind of way of using logic as a
way to kind of symbolically describe
things about the world
okay so then we're in the 1970s one of
the one of the things that became a big
thing at that time was so-called expert
systems
um it was a bit of a mushy concept but
kind of the idea was somehow encode in a
in a software system kind of the
knowledge of experts and people had this
kind of view that um you know they would
interview the experts I remember kind of
oil exploration experts you know being
interviewed and and it was like oh my
gosh we're going to lose our jobs
because after we've been interviewed
once all of our knowledge will have been
sucked out and put in the giant
electronic brain that is the the expert
system and then that's all that will be
needed and the expert system will be
able to figure out everything that
experts were previously supposed to do
needless to say didn't work out at the
time as as had been hoped uh in fact um
uh there were a number of companies
about my first company
um ended up as a result of venture
capital pressure uh my first company was
originally called computer mathematics
Corporation later changed its name to
inference corporation uh sounds rather
modern nowadays I suppose but um uh I
thought um uh it was kind of the the
concept was to sort of it it started off
kind of as a company to uh commercialize
my first big Software System SMP that I
developed in 1979 to 1981
um that was kind of a forerunner of
mathematical and morphing language
um a technical computation system but uh
under Venture Capital pressure the
company kind of decided to sort of add
on a big effort in expert systems and
tried to make kind of a a language for
expert systems which I was not really
involved in and I have to say I the uh I
never really understand stood you know I
don't know whether it was any good at
all but any case it was used for a
number of early significant expert
systems for the early reporting systems
were built by by my first company and a
bunch of things for for NASA for
um uh checking things for you know is
are we ready to launch the spacecraft
type thing and a bunch of other kinds of
there are lots of inputs and you're kind
of going to make rules that determine
whether you do this or that thing
honestly it would have probably been
better to have used SMP as the framework
for setting up those kinds of rules and
and the the actions from those rules but
that wasn't what was done at the time
one lives and learns I have not um uh uh
in the last 40 something years notably
um I my company is not a bench Capital
uh investment based company
um it's uh I kind of I kind of learned
from that experience that um if you have
a vision for what you want to do then
you should be responsible for it and not
have other people telling you oh no no
we saw in the newspaper that there's
another there's a cool thing you can do
the word newspapers back up in those
days
um and uh you know maybe the company
should go chase this this new shiny
object
um not not um uh not the best thing I
would say that company just if you're
curious that company eventually
um in the 1990s actually went public in
a rather undistinguished IPO
um and uh uh the um
um was rapidly gobbled up by a long
chain of other other companies but any
case the um that was that was another
kind of moment was kind of the expert
systems moment in the 70s 19 late 1970s
1980s and so on
uh which brings us I suppose to the
beginning of the 1980s there was a
another burst of enthusiasm for neural
Nets and the beginning of kind of using
uh deep neural Nets and so on
multi-layer neural Nets that avoided the
Minsky puppet nothing interesting
happens with perceptrons type um uh type
thing and people came up with pretty
elaborate increasingly elaborate kinds
of constructions but but neuron that's
in the end most of those elaborate
constructions don't matter but and in
the end the things that were sort of the
early things that were done when you
bash them hard enough with with you know
efficient enough gpus CPUs whatever
um it it's enough but any case back at
that time there was sort of another
burst of enthusiasm for neural Nets
um beginning of the 1980s I would say
that some part of that enthusiasm segued
into kind of a a let's use neural Nets
as a way to think about modeling of
brains rather than let's use normal
that's as a practical way to do
something that would be sort of AI like
um but any case the the thing that um uh
maybe I've told this the story
separately but but um
kind of by
uh sort of the whole neural and that
sort of thing yeah they were always a
thing people like me didn't really think
they were going to do anything terribly
interesting I'd looked at them we had
packages for Waffen language and so on
then Mathematica
um that did neural that kinds of things
they were like well nice to have but
they're not that exciting and it wasn't
clear whether they were things that
would be of technological software
significance whether they were mostly
things that would be of of significance
for um
uh for understanding actual brains there
had been some technology that had been
built using neural nets for example
optical character recognition the
standard software that was doing that uh
ended up being neural net based
um that happened I would say by the
1990s for sure but it was still the case
that even in sort of object recognition
things like this that you know kind of
hacks based on image processing out did
things that were based on neural Nets
and that hap that continued to be the
case until 2012 2012 uh Jeff Hinton and
his students
um uh Jeff Hinton have been a person who
worked on neural Nets back in 1980 when
that sort of burst of enthusiasm at that
time
um that had kind of trained this deep
neural Nets kind of left it training for
a month or something and when they kind
of came back turned out the thing had
done pretty well at learning how to
classify a few thousand different kinds
of things and images the so-called
imagenet competition and it won the
image.com petition in 2012 I guess and
that started this big enthusiasm of deep
learning and this whole sort of idea
that they're going to be neural Nets
that do all these different kinds of
things and first for object recognition
um then lots of different applications
that um well then then I forget the
ordering of them another big one had
been was Speech to Text Speech to Text
had been a thing that had really been
started in the 19 uh well 60s I guess to
1970s this whole speech recognition uh
method there was a lot of interest in
doing speech recognition IBM had a big
effort in speech recognition for example
curiously most of the people from that
group ended up going to Jim Simons as
Renaissance technology uh hedge fund
um perhaps because one of their early
ideas for kind of predict the market was
um actually listen to The Sounds on the
on the trading floor at the Chicago
Board of Trade to try and predict
options prices moments before they would
sort of show up as actual transactions
but in any case that was also a general
idea of of speech recognition as an
example of pattern recognition and that
became important in Quant finance and so
on but um uh there had been this long
tradition of of kind of speech to text
and typically what people did in speech
to text was they would be the whole sort
of audio processing part there would be
let's break it into phonemes let's kind
of match up you know this group of
phonemes that became more like a test
retrieval story of this group of
phonemes
um would be uh
um
uh would be put together to make a make
a particular word and so on and that was
kind of a um uh
um a thing that um
um
was uh then there were companies like
Dragon systems was an early company that
made um uh
um uh made speech to text systems I
think that was one that um had managed
to get speech to text to run on PCS it
was it was always a big deal to have
speech to text run on PCS because it was
a very time intensive thing and uh that
it also mattered a lot what the quality
of the audio was
and then they started to be neural net
systems for doing this and pretty much
the whole sort of structure of very
elaborately built speech to text
statistical speech to text systems kind
of fell away to something where you
would train end to end uh on uh with
with with neural Nets to do it I mean
another thing that was a big deal this
must have been around well actually this
was already in 2010 when Siri first came
out uh the um we had Syria was
originally a a part of a an outfit
called SRI it was a sort of a research
object and actually it's kind of a core
but it was really The Wolfman Alpha uh
computational knowledge engine and then
it had sort of overlaid on top of that a
voice to text system
um that came from nuance and um then
the uh uh but nuanced system which had
come from I think Dragon systems I think
Nuance had kind of brought up a lot of
the different um
um uh companies that were in the speech
to text business uh some people
complained a lot about its business
practices about doing that but um uh I
think another one was verbex systems and
a whole bunch of others whose names I
probably don't remember now
um but in a case that it sort of rolled
them all together and had the speech to
text system that um uh
um was the thing used for uh sort of the
original series before before Syria was
part of Apple
um but uh already by that time speech to
text was starting to work fairly well
and that was before neural Nets uh
really started doing speech to text
um and and the big sort of innovation at
that time was that you could run
multiple possible interpretations of the
speech all in parallel and you can kind
of compare which one worked best and
that was really a matter for sort of how
powerful the cloud servers were but then
by
mid-2010s uh there were really
end-to-end neural Nets speech-to-text
systems and that became quite a
commoditized kind of thing
the the notion of
uh having well a series of different
kinds of things became sort of uh things
that neural Nets could do we're still
not quite at the handwriting recognition
stage that's still a thing that's out
there we're not quite at the at the good
voice generation stage that's still
still under development uh the sort of
the big excitement of recent times has
been text continuation or the kinds of
things that uh chat GPT does is
fundamentally a text continuation system
uh that have been again a long series of
language models that tried to continue
text that date well you can think of
them dating all the way back to the
1940s and Shannon's work on information
Theory and I'm figuring out kind of the
redundancy of English text through
things about text retrieval and so on
that those were all the through things
about speech recognition these all used
language models and that's something
which Now by sort of taking the whole
web and lots of books and so on it
becomes possible it's turned out it's
possible to train a language model that
also has sort of backup knowledge in it
that um uh can do very impressive things
I think that the the thing that is a
surprise with track GPT is its
instruction following capabilities and
the fact that it can sort of do what one
tells it to do in some sense and not
sort of get get lost off in the in the
wilderness and so on that's the thing
which really has made it sort of pop at
a touring test level
um in a way that that really hadn't
happened with with earlier language
models and I think it's sort of in some
sense more a question of engineering
than it has been a question of other
things to really add that extra layer
that's um that's made that really work
so well but any case the the um uh you
know so anyway the the sort of by the
2010s you know neural Nets sort of were
a thing meanwhile on the kind of
symbolic side of things it's kind of
pretty much us whether I suppose a a
large part of the the effort there of
building well first wolf language as a
kind of computational representation of
the world and being able to actually
take kind of the knowledge that exists
in kind of formal form and be able to
make it something that you can compute
things with and then wolf Alpha from
um which was the first successful uh
natural language understanding
um kind of uh natural language to
computational language uh to computation
system and uh in fact and remains really
the only one that does that in a
sophisticated way
um the uh you know people had tried to
make sort of language understanding
systems back uh it had been kind of a
common AI kind of idea
um to do that but the problem was what
does it mean to understand language what
does it mean what is the what is the
output what is the thing that you get
when you say yes I can understand
language
um the uh
uh and what we had when we built wolf
malpha was we had a Target we know we
were taking uh sort of human language
and we were converting it into this
computational language from which we
could do computations I mean I have to
say to give an example I I should
emphasize that in the 1980s for example
AI was a small field there were not very
many people doing it uh you could kind
of name there was the MIT group there
was the Stanford group there was uh
maybe I'm not sure if Carnegie Mellon
was yet really a factor there but there
were there were these groups in
different places there were a few
different Traditions there was a
cybernetics tradition in the in the
Soviet Union there was a uh there had
been some uh there were different
traditions in different places but there
really wasn't a large-scale field of of
artificial intelligence and there were
these individual groups in different
places I remember visiting a group at
Yale this must be in the mid-1980s and
uh I can tell a weird story about that
we give some sense of the state of
artificial intelligence research uh they
said yeah I drop in and that's like this
is the AI research group and they're
they're like we have the system that
translates Spanish into English and I'm
like wow you know this is the 1980s that
that isn't a thing yet
um you know very impressive let me see
it work
and it's like and you know what what do
I do where do I type
um I said well you know and I said I
don't really know much Spanish but I can
try and make something up and and type
something and see what happens I said
well you don't really understand doesn't
really do that it it translates stories
from Spanish into English said okay how
long do I need to how long does it need
to be to be a story and by the way that
the fact that it would translate stories
not shorter things actually in the way
that language translation has evolved
wouldn't have been such a crazy idea
because it needed some context and
things like this in any case that was
that was the thing so then I was like
well no it it isn't any story it's
particular stories so it's like okay
well what kind of stories I mean is it
stories about like fairy tales is it
what kind of stories is it well okay
eventually you know eventually it comes
down to well actually the system
translates one particular story from
Spanish into English and I'm like what
the heck is this this is not a software
system that does something general this
is something quite different and you
know the description was well we're
trying to understand how you would
translate something from Spanish to
English what the sort of structural
correspondences between parse trees and
all this kind of thing are
that was kind of the state of of that
was a common you know that was
considered to be a reasonable AI project
in the mid-1980s uh that was you know
that was kind of the the state that
things had got to people were then doing
things like uh there were you know very
very toy projects I mean things were the
blocks were where you would try and plan
how to move a block from here to there
it ended up being sort of a simple
program that uh tried to do that
Etc et cetera et cetera it really was a
surprisingly I mean what what really
happened I think in that field is that
people had the idea that they would make
toy problems and and study them it just
turns out that sort of I think AI is a
is a creature of kind of uh it's it's
it's a creature where you either have
something complicated or you have
nothing at all and I think we saw that
in in Wolf malpha for example until it
had knowledge of a lot of things in the
world until it could computed about a
lot of things in the world it really
wasn't terribly useful and uh you know
when we launched it by the time we
launched it it could compute about a lot
of different kinds of things in the
world but it was undemoable until
shortly before it was launched because
it really just didn't you know you would
say something and it was just like oh I
don't know anything about that kind of
thing
so
and similarly with neural Nets kind of
there was the assumption that the toy
simple problem would be much easier to
deal with and the big thing that
involves you know gazillions of
variables and different uh weights in
the neural net and so on that turned out
to be wrong it turned out to be the case
that it was easier to train these very
big complicated neural Nets than to
train a small neural net and the reason
for that was the training is kind of
like you keep bashing it sort of an
evolutionary process to try and make it
so that its weights
are closer to doing the things you want
and when you have a large number of
Weights it's like a high dimensional
space you can always find a path to get
to where you want to go but if it's a
low dimensional space a small number of
Weights it's really easy to get stuck
and there's just no way to get there
from here so to speak
well anyway the um uh
um
let's see so that was a little bit of um
uh kind of a a quick history of of uh
some aspects of AI I think that um one
of the things
that
continues to be an interesting well okay
so then there's AI in real life there's
AI in the movies
and some of these things sort of
converge with each other and intermingle
with each other I mean there were there
were early
uh what was it rosson's Universal robots
that's 1929 or something was the
original sort of robot idea I'm not sure
I've ever seen that movie I have to
admit
um but that was a um that was a kind of
a workers and robots type story I think
I think it was a Czech movie
Czechoslovakian check whatever chechnya
check I don't even know I think it was
Czechoslovakia in those days I'm not
sure
um but uh
the um uh in any case that was a movie
that um uh was sort of I was I as I
remember
um was sort of talking about robots as
the mechanical workers type thing and
then much later while there was a movie
in the mid-1950s called desk set was it
that was an amusing movie which we uh
looked at when we were launching wolfen
Alpha it's a movie where uh there's a
Mainframe computer and a librarian and
the you know the librarian's been doing
their job and and then the Mainframe
computer is wheeled in and the Mainframe
computer is able to answer all these
reference library questions and so when
we launched wolf Marvel we made sure
that yes it could actually answer the
questions that were asked to the
computer in um uh in the in the desk set
movie from the mid-1950s that movie
wasn't particularly notable I think it
had famous actress in it forget who
um but any case we could ask both
malfoot would surely know
um the uh
in any case the thing that um
um
yeah but by the way I mean I should say
one of the things that
sort of made well from alpha possible
was kind of the existence of large-scale
databases of information about lots of
kinds of things those would have existed
independent of the web many of those
long predated the web
for things like language training like
large language models having the web you
know the six billion web pages or
something that are uh sort of reasonably
human written and reasonably accessible
on the web that's super useful and um
and then you know there are 100 million
books and so on and about I don't know
maybe 10 million or 10 million of those
have been scanned and ocr'd
um and that's another very useful
training set that kind of is a thing of
modern times that those large training
sets have existed but going back to sort
of the science fiction uh portrayals of
AI the um
probably the next really uh two that
were notable were 2001 Space Odyssey and
Star Trek 2001 A Space Odyssey features
the HAL 9000 that was originally you
know IBM was the was the organization
that was the consultants for for that
movie and originally there was a name
plate that said IBM and that nameplate
was replaced it was kind of glued you
know on top of that was a nameplate that
said how it was people noted to Arthur C
Clarke and so on that Hal is you know
IBM with a letter a letter reduced in
the alphabet so to speak I think that
was not intentional it would but was
intentional it was the case of the
nameplate used to say IBM it was covered
up to say how because the executives at
IBM thought it was too scarier concept
this was in 1968-ish when 2001 came out
it was too scarier concept that their
customers would be being told that an AI
is going to take over human jobs uh
something which interesting that that
was a sensitive issue for the the public
relations folk of IBM in the mid-1960s
um but any case that was that was they
didn't want that portrayed there the
fact that the computer turned psychotic
was apparently less important than the
concept that the computer would sort of
take over over human jobs
but maybe it didn't sound psychotic I
don't know it depends how you interpret
that movie
um in any case the the um
the thing that um this notion I mean
Marvin Minsky was a consultant on the
2001 movie and a bunch of the things
that you see Hal doing in that movie
were things where people were sort of
specifically thinking this is going to
be a sign of AI it was playing chess it
was drawing sketches it was uh doing
various kinds of prediction about what
about failure of components things like
this
um so and then it was doing lip reading
that was that was a movie I think added
concept
um but and then there was the Star Trek
computer actually uh for various reasons
we're just looking again at what the
actual dialogue With The Star Trek
computer had been it's not as wolfen
Alpha information seeking like as one
might have remembered it to be it's
mostly things like you know uh set the
phases to whatever it is and that it's
more like commands to do things rather
than it is uh information seeking kinds
of things but the notion in the Star
Trek computer of the uh and how you know
more or less at the same time of these
speaking computers that would have kind
of an AI
um uh kind of
motif was was was a a sort of a thing of
that time and and really a a sign of the
the expectation about what would go on I
mean it's notable in 2001 that you see
screens on the uh well for example they
didn't have the idea of multi-window
displays so every different function was
a different physical screen
um and if you look to occasionally in
that movie I I looked at it at one point
frame by frame because I was curious and
writing a big piece about about the 50th
anniversary of 2001
um and and presumably uh 2018.
um the uh
uh that was um if you look at the
screens occasionally they would flash up
code and that code was kind of a weird
mixture of Fortran pl1 like code and it
was kind of interesting that people
imagined that that would be the way that
code would look uh a very much like
modern low-level programming languages
look I have to say
um but that there will be the how up at
the you know up talking to people and
then there would be this code that that
looks just like sort of Fortran or
um well then PL one code or something
like that
um but in any case the um
you know then the kind of the the notion
of of AI and movies uh uh you know AIS
have this this terrible you know they're
often the the the the villains and the
movies I think there's some what was it
the this movie is it called short
circuit I think that must have been from
the 80s 90s something like that where
it's uh where a kind of a much more
um amused and amusing kind of accidental
AI comes to life I always like the
spoiler for the end of the movie I
suppose is that um this uh this AI
eventually it sort of it it gets somehow
emancipated and it creates a company
called Data Inc and um uh some giant
company where it's it's some uh it's
kind of ingesting data about the world
that sort of appealed to me
um but in any case the the um uh you
know there are other movies like
Terminator for example
um I do find it amusing if I haven't I
have to look at this again but as I
recall in Terminator
um the uh this very kind of
old-fashioned and intentionally
old-fashioned kind of screen displays of
what the Terminator sort of sees as it's
trying to decide what to do and if I
remember correctly and I should go check
this
um I think it has kind of a
probabilistic thing of their possible
phrases that um uh to say in a
particular circumstance and it ends up
with some expletive written phrase but
um uh it's kind of amused me that in
large language models it's sort of the
same story that every word every next
thing to say there's a certain
probability to say the next thing and
you pick one of those things and then
you say it and then you go on and that's
kind of how large language models work
it's kind of interesting that that would
be a thing in in Terminator
um and in any case I think um uh the um
um yeah I noticed somebody commenting
here on amazing how well 2001 holds up
yeah I mean I I watched it again in 2018
I wrote this this long piece about what
what was what worked out what didn't uh
things about
um uh you know the video phone uh that
was almost made it in 2001 I I mean I
used a video for him in 2001 but but it
had been it had been a thing that was
demoed at the World's Fair in the 1950s
video phone but it wasn't you know
nowadays we are sort of routinely using
video through computers which wasn't
what people had imagined they imagined
there would be just video phones well of
course the phone network the phone
system the Bell System and so on was a
very dominant technology player back in
the 1950s 1960s and so on where it
really was they made phones I mean there
were computers behind the scenes but
they made phones that was the sort of
consumer delivery of everything that
they had
well uh
let's see I think I should um probably
uh okay prabh is asking let me try and
um
uh
let's see
uh just a couple of things following up
on what I've been saying here and then
we should wrap up for today
um
gosh M rudo asks what what does pattern
matching look like in the Middle Ages
you know this whole question about sort
of the the formalization of thinking and
its role in Middle Ages uh I I think the
the character who's probably one of the
more notable ones is Ramon Lal from the
who's Catalan I believe lived in the
majorca-ish area
um among other places he was sort of a
Mystic meets mathematician
who had around 1200 as I recall who had
um uh this kind of scheme where he had
this kind of diagram where you'd have
words in the diagram and you'd kind of
spin a spinner and it'd be like telling
you that follow this word with this word
with this word to make up the sentence
to say what was going to happen and he
kind of had this notion that that the
the things that could be said about the
world were represented by possible sort
of configurations in this diagram and
that was uh that was kind of a Middle
Ages version of kind of the
formalization of thinking obviously
there had been the notion of syllogistic
logic from Aristotle that had continued
very much into the Middle Ages people
like abelard and um and so on uh Peter
Avalon
um who was was one of the kind of people
who who pushed that forward and but it
didn't really you know it was really
these patterns of of uh exactly the same
patterns I think chat GPT has noticed in
language things like you know the
Barbara and the cellular celerant and so
on
syllogisms of uh you know these
structures and language that would allow
you to make inferences
um and that was that was I would say
sort of formal AI in the AI in the
Middle Ages was probably so logistic
logic and by the 1600s people like
leibniz was starting to try and think
more about the sort of formalization of
arguments by Logic and and then that
evolved to later to frager and people
like that in the 1800s but that was I
think I think that was probably what um
what was um
um
uh what was going on there okay one last
thing here is a question from prab
what's the relationship between
cybernetics and Ai and uh how do the
words sort of cyber well okay so I
believe the term cybernetics was
invented by Norbert wiener it comes from
the Latin gubernator uh with a g g u b
um and uh it which means a Helmsman and
uh it's kind of like who steers the ship
who controls what's going on and that
led uh we know who was interested who
had worked on anti-aircraft guns in
World War II where where it's kind of
like you see the plane which got to move
the gun to a place that's different from
where you see the plane and and so on
how do you do that automatically how do
you do that quickly you have to make an
electronic device that does it and that
was kind of an early version of control
theory but then the um I mean you know
what we know wrote a book about
cybernetics I remember reading that in
probably 1975 or so
um and uh uh I have to say it was
I I thought it was a funny book because
it had sort of at some level it had this
kind of very qualitative description of
kind of the big picture of you know
control of things in animals and so on
and then it jumped into some sort of uh
mathematics that was fairly elaborate
mathematics but it wasn't clear
connected that much to the big picture
of what was being said now in the early
days of cybernetics uh you know in the
in the 1950s there were cyberneticians
and even today there are there are
cyberneticians I suppose mostly I would
say in in Europe and places like that
more so than in the US and then
cybernetics became a big thing in Russia
for a while and Soviet Union for a while
but um the the thing that um uh kind of
cybernetics
was kind of at some level the
application of computational ideas to
things like animals and their you know
motion and robots and maybe a little bit
to the brains and how they were thinking
about things
um I would say that the uh
cybernetics as a field was very big in
the 1950s there were these Macy
conferences organized by the um I guess
the the paid for at least by the family
of the Macy's department store folks
um same people has funded the original
Institute for advanced study I think in
Princeton
um the uh uh
unless I'm mistaken this that was the
bambogers department store maybe it was
uh anyway the um uh department stores
where I guess a very um uh you know one
of the the booming businesses in those
days but in any case the the thing that
um
was um uh cybernetics was this big thing
in the 1950s it kind of broke into
pieces one piece became control theory
engineering control theory very
practical stuff PID controllers all the
kinds of things that actually run you
know automatic transmission in cars and
thermostats and HVAC systems all those
kinds of things that's one piece not
very much didn't feel very brain like
maybe more like the endocrine system in
in organisms but not very kind of brain
and thinking like
then there was sort of another branch
that turned into what we might now talk
about as complexity research complex
systems research I have to say that
Branch was very dead at the time when I
started sort of talking about complex
systems and thinking about how complex
Behavior could arise from simple
components and so on in the early 1980s
that was really really had very much
died by that time and I suppose the um
um the the kind of there were then sort
of I don't know it was it was a word
like I remember and Doctor Who uh
British television series which I guess
is still going
um I remember watching that when I was a
kid in the in the
oh first of the mid-1960s there was this
um uh the villains there was one set of
villains called the Daleks there was
another set of villains called the
Cybermen and and I think that might have
been the first time that I had heard
this kind of cyber prefix
um and you know they were robotic you
know silver you know well in the actual
television series people wearing a bunch
of silver clothing but but uh you know
in modern it would be CGI in modern
times of some kind of robotic uh
whatever they were but that was an early
use in the sort of public uh sphere of
of uh kind of the Cyber term
um but it really didn't uh and then then
uh gosh I don't know the the way that it
sort of merged with the whole cyberpunk
movement and cyber cyber security and
computer security and the whole meaning
of cyber as a computer prefix
um is uh I'm not sure when that that
happened sometime in the 1990s think
that that really became a thing
um and uh but really it was sort of a
weird kind of distortion of the original
concept of cybernetics as it had existed
in the 1950s
all right I should wrap it up here well
thanks for joining me and um uh
um
maybe there'll be some interesting uh
developments even in the near future in
the in the world of uh of the history of
AI we'll have to see
thanks very much and uh bye for now